Hi, this is Sean Mitchell, assistant scout master with troop number 27 in Snyder, Texas.
In this edition of the Scout Master podcast is brought to you by Backers Like Me
And now it's to you. Scout Master,
We met a through hiker going southbound.
He was two days away from finishing.
He said: what's the difference between a day hiker, a weekender, and a through hiker?
The day hiker, when they see food on the ground, passes by it.
The weekender, when they see food on the ground, picks it up, brushes off the dirt and eats
it.
And the through hiker eats it and then starts digging for more.
Sounds about right.
Yeah,
Hey, this is podcast number 338..
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Wow,
Today is going to be fun.
So I found out a week or so ago a couple of my old Eagle Scouts were off to hike the
Appalachian Trail.
I was able to get in touch with them and record a conversation that I had a lot of fun doing.
But before we go to that conversation, I want to pause and thank all the folks who are
ScoutMasterCGcom backers and patrons.
You're the ones who keep this going and make it possible for me to keep up with
the blog and the podcast
Really do appreciate all of your support.
If you'd like to become a backer or join our patron subscribers, visit ScoutMasterCGcom.
You'll find links to follow at the top right of any page and links in this episode's podcast
notes.
In a moment you're going to hear two of my old Eagle Scouts-
The first one you'll hear. his name is Wade Bastion,
And then he'll be joined by his hiking partner, Bucky Kellogg,
And we'll have a great time talking about what they're up to
And we'll also recall their first backpacking trip, which I remember to some extent,
But they remember in much more detail than I do.
And before we get to that conversation, I'm going to play a song from Bucky's band
Lost Festingos that I think is reasonably fitting to the occasion.
If you look at the podcast notes, you can get a copy of the song if you like.
So let's get started. shall we,
Stepping to my forest, feel the magic in the air?
I know that you're not evil.
I know deep down you care.
I cannot help but wonder why you do the things you do.
I hope you will remember that it's applied it to
Cause I am a Sasquatch
And I live among the trees,
And I am proud to be a Sasquatch.
I live in peace and harmony,
In harmony.
Tell everybody where you are right now.
Right now I am in Hiawasi, Georgia, in a Holiday Inn Express.
And what are you doing in Hiawasi, Georgia?
I am here on a zero day from the Appalachian Trail.
We're hiking from Georgia to Maine.
And when did you start?
We started just about a week ago.
Last Monday actually was our first day.
And tell me what a zero day is?
So a zero day is when you're feeling just a bit too lazy to hike,
So you just end up doing nothing.
So we're doing nothing in a town where people are who will get offended by how bad we smell.
Well, that's nothing new,
Yeah,
Yeah, no.
Well, I mean now it's just like more pungent, but just by far.
I would say the letters TMI right now are too much information.
Where did this idea come from that you're going to go and hike the Appalachian Trail?
This idea came from Bucky
And I guess when he gets back he can tell it.
But I'll give my little bit here.
He has always wanted to through hike.
He's done different sections, like he did all over a month.
He's always really wanted to hike
And he got to a point with his job, where everything just came in to line.
I had a couple months where I didn't have a job and nothing better to do,
So I just decided: why not join him
Now? I'm actually going to throw it on speakerphone, because Bucky has just come back in the room.
Bucky, what's up?
What's up with you?
I am sitting in a relatively dry and comfortable place.
I understand that you are now for the first time in a week.
No, no,
We spent two nights in a hostel two nights ago.
Wait a minute,
Let's back up.
Hospital,
Hostel,
Hostel.
Okay,
Tell me how everything got started and then tell me about the first week on the trail.
I was feeling like I needed to make some changes,
So I was already thinking about doing the trail.
I gave my boss notice.
I gave her like six months notice or three months notice,
So this isn't something that you decided to do like last week.
No,
As my camping trips usually are, this time it was not.
This one was relatively well planned.
Yeah,
We did a lot of that, though,
And we're definitely better prepared for having Wade here than I would have been by myself.
So you have things like food and a tent and clothing.
Yeah,
I probably would have had some food, a hammock and some stuff,
But we planned out meals together and then Wade did a lot of drying while I was
finishing up work.
So we have 117 dried meals-
Yeah,
Wow-
Of eight different varieties.
But you're not carrying them all right now,
Oh no,
I made that mistake.
So we got them all ready and vacuum sealed them.
I brought them all over to Bucky's house and Bucky's mom is going to mail them to us
at intervals throughout the trip.
That's a pretty usual way that people do this, isn't it?
It's a little better prepared than most people- or not most people, but like, I feel like half
of the people are that prepared and then half of them are flying by to see their pants.
Yeah,
We've met some people already that are just like, just kind of going for it.
There was the one guy who said he started out with like a 75 pound pack or something
like that, with all MREs.
Yeah,
Nothing but MREs in his pack.
75 pounds.
Yeah,
That's what he said.
He said he was just offering MREs to people because he just said so much,
Wait in his pack.
Oh my,
Oh my.
Yeah,
I am in no way fishing for compliments, but if they happen to fall. that's fine.
Where did you get into backpacking and hiking and things like that?
Oh gosh,
There's this real old man. I knew
What was his name.
Yeah,
Tony's held a beard.
Oh yeah,
First time I really went hiking was on the Appalachian Trail in Pennsylvania
with the troop, with you, and I was so unprepared for that trip.
I wore sneakers and had one of those camp more like external frame packs,
And I remember the sec, the like Saturday of the trip.
it was only like a 10, 12 mile trip total,
but I remember the last mile or so to the shelter.
I was just sobbing,
I was in so much pain.
Mr Keen was behind me and he was just trying to keep my spirits up
and asked me if I liked Harry Potter and things like that,
And I was just so sad.
Oh man,
I was hurting so bad.
How old were you?
12.?
Okay,
I'm sorry
I interrupted you,
Keep going.
So, yeah,
No, I was just sobbing and hurt and so bad.
And then so we get to the shelter and water was maybe a tenth of a mile down the hill
And it seemed like forever.
So I went down and one of the other adult leaders was spilling up water bottles
And I only had two like plastic, like Dasani water bottles- just like you know-
not now jeans or anything-
And one of the water bottles I had put my free chewed gum into because I thought
it would make the water minty
And then when I, when the water was filled back up in a gum, had dissolved.
So when there was clean water in there, it was just disgusting,
It was just absolutely horrible.
So I only really had one liter of water to go the rest of that night
And the next morning out.
So that was my introduction to backpacking.
For some reason I liked it enough to go the next year
And it's just got better from there.
But yeah, that was, that was my first time.
That was my first time hiking.
So it was memorable for you.
Definitely memorable,
Bucky. do you remember the first hiking trip you went on?
That was my first backpacking as well,
Because remember the first backpacking trip I should have gone on
being a year ahead of Wade,
I showed up at the church crying and refused to go.
I do recall that
I wasn't going to mention it, but now that you mentioned it
I figured I might as well like preclude that and embarrass myself.
That's probably a big driver as to why I wanted to do this,
Because it was one of those like, oh, I missed my dad,
Like I don't want to do this without him,
And then I didn't go.
And then every year after that I went and regretted not going
that first time, though
Wade's first trip was quite memorable.
You would have been a little more experienced than he,
Yeah,
And just like a little bit older.
Somebody was carrying a pot on the outside of their pack and
Mr Mann kept filling it with rocks.
And then
what else happened on that trip?
I think maybe Andrew Mattingly carried, went back and carried
somebody's pack for them.
I can't remember who it was because he packed way too much.
Oh yeah,
Yeah, that was. that was. that was an interesting trip.
That was an eventful trip.
Was there anyone that wasn't?
No, no,
Every backpacking trip I can remember from Scouts-
Yeah, there were. there was always things that happened.
There was the wrong foot, the wrong shoes on the wrong feet
incident.
That was a fun one.
That was. that was like four trips in. for me, though,
Yeah, that was when we were like old and we were doing the
people who are listening, or volunteer Scouts. they're
looking at the younger guys in their troops who are
not very well prepared, who don't really know what
they're going through or what they're up against,
And they're kind of wondering: is it a good idea to
take these guys out backpacking, or do they ever
learn anything?
Or why is it so frustratingly horrible for like
11 and 12 year old? sometimes,
I don't. I don't think it's just frustratingly
horrible for 11 and 12 year old,
It's frustratingly horrible for everybody.
Somehow
Outdoor masochistic minds, we've decided that this is
fun and we're going to have fun, but it's really
not that fun.
The fun part is when you're stopped and like
talking to people and hanging around a camp and
like getting water,
And I don't think that that's necessarily just the
problem of the 11 and 12 year olds.
I think what really helps is make helping them be
as prepared as they possibly can, which is all you
can hope for anyone, but nobody really remembers
how hard it is until they're doing it.
Yeah, I know it's always sounds like such a
great thing.
Yeah, let's go walk the entire Appalachian
Trail.
That'll be cool,
Except for the part where it rains every day.
Yeah,
Do you think when you were 11 or 12 that anybody
could explain the experience to you in a way
that you would actually be prepared.
I think explaining like verbally what would
never do it justice.
But when you take all the gear and lay it out
and have them pick off the pack and say,
all right, like carry this around the block,
I think we started doing that where we just
like brought 30 pounds of canned food and put
it in a backpack and we're like this is what
it's going to feel like
That was a more efficient descriptor than
anything else. or overloading a pack and putting
it on somebody and being like this is what
it feels like after 10 miles.
But you did that with some guys who still
didn't understand.
That's true.
Yeah,
I don't know.
I think it's very, very tough to describe
how difficult it really is.
Yeah,
Until you're crying at the end of the day.
But here's my point:
You can't really understand what you're
doing in a lot of stuff that scouts do
until you actually do it and then you learn
how to do it and it gets better,
Absolutely.
Yeah,
That is very true.
Before my first trip you could have told me
how great hiking boots are. all day long
I would have still shown up in sneakers
And I'm glad I learned that, because now
I know the value of good footwear,
And that's one of those things you learn
on trips like that, because it's better
than learning it alone.
At least you've got other people there who've
done this several times and like, yeah,
all right, buddy,
This is how you set up camps,
This is how you start a fire,
Or this is how you go hiking like this.
It's those experiences on the trips
that will help you, I guess. learn
the lessons, learn how to do everything
you need to do.
I think that's a big part of what
scouting does- to make people better
People- is you get humbled constantly
at that age where you need to be humbled,
Where you're like: I know everything better
than all of these people telling me what I should do,
And then you do it wrong and you're like,
oh, I should have done it that way.
And it helps you listen in a very harsh way:
Yeah,
Dang that guy,
I hate him, but he's right.
Yeah,
Yeah.
And it helps you be more accepting of that,
when somebody tells you something, to actually
think about it instead of be like,
no, I'm going to do it my way because it's my way.
Yeah, just like 75 pounds of MREs,
Why not?
Yeah, exactly,
Exactly.
There's all kinds of platitudes about through hiking
and everything about everybody hikes their own hike.
I think it happens in scouts-
maybe in a smaller context,
but I don't know. when you're 11 or 12 or 13 years old,
it's a pretty big context for you.
I think it's just as sizable in scouts
as it is now hitting it.
I mean, we're 52.4 miles in or something like that,
And we've been hit hard.
It's not necessarily the same lesson
because we were better prepared than we were
when we were scouts,
but it's the same sort of message.
You both went on to become eagle scouts
in spite of everything.
Yeah,
It's amazing how that happened.
So how long ago was that?
For me, my paperwork was submitted
just before the deadline,
So that was early 2010..
That was, yeah, seven years ago,
2008 for me,
And you were a little less of a deadline guy.
I think I was maybe a month ahead
of being on the deadline.
Yeah, I was paperwork submitted
just before my 18th birthday.
Yeah,
I do remember that way
because you were one of the guys
where we were counting hours.
Yeah,
It was pretty close, but I made it.
It's been either seven or nine years, right,
So worth doing.
Absolutely.
Yeah, absolutely,
In the years since becoming an eagle scout.
I mean, I've still been involved in scouts.
I think last year is one of the first years
where I really wasn't involved.
One of the great things that happened in the process
of becoming an eagle scout
was learning how to work with other people
and how to manage a project like that
and how to manage other people more so
than just being a patrol leader,
seeing a patrol leader
actually having a significant task at hand
and being able to accomplish it,
because that transferred into working at Camp Horseshoe,
that transferred into being trained
at National Camp School
and then working at National Camp School.
There were so many skills that I learned there
that really helped out
And those were things that I started learning
with the eagle project.
So I definitely really enjoyed doing it.
What translates for you, Bucky?
I think a large part of my person comes from that task.
I think that's probably to this point.
one of my greatest accomplishments would be getting eagle,
And it was kind of alarming that I did
because I hit first class and just sat there
And I was like I don't care.
And then I think when I say around 16,
I was like, well, I'm going to do this.
So I had to scramble again,
But the takeaway is definitely communication skills,
leadership skills.
It's one of those things that sounds kind of cheesy to say
I'd be like be in a scout
taught me how to be a leader,
But it really did.
And it also taught me when other people take charge,
because I have a problem with that.
After I got a taste of control as a patrol leader-
I loved it way too much,
But you learned to take a backseat after,
Because I was. I think I was surprised
after I was senior patrol leader
And I maybe did something else after senior patrol leader.
So I had to go back to being answering to somebody else
and letting them fill that role
And I think that was almost just as important
as learning to be a leader is when to be a leader.
That's pretty interesting.
I like that.
That's a good thought.
Like when you understand how to lead things,
you also understand more about how to be a decent follower.
I think that's something that we picked up from someone named
Clark: letting us make our own mistakes.
It was invaluable.
There's a big learning in making the mistakes yourself
and then having someone there that can laugh a little
and say I told you so, but also we know that it's there
to help us if we really need it.
So we weren't incredibly cruel, just kind of normally cruel.
No, no, no, no,
You're cruel at just the right time-
Surgical cruelness, you know.
So what do your folks think of all this?
My parents are very excited.
My mom has wanted me to hike the Appalachian Trail
for a very long time
And I don't want to say I never really wanted to,
but I never really thought I would-
And she had friends who would go and hike
and do all these sorts of things.
And she would always get very excited and like, wait,
what are you going to do this?
And I never really thought about doing it.
So when the idea came up, when Bucky was first pitching me
the idea of, like I'm doing this, are you coming with me?
And I was sort of sold right then
I first told my mom because my dad would have freaked out
and been like: no, you can't run away into the woods
for a couple of months,
Because that's what I do all summer already.
So I went to my mom's first and was like, mom,
I think I'm going to hike the trail with Bucky.
And she was like, she was so excited.
She was in the first moment
She was like: yes, absolutely,
That's great,
I'll get you a guidebook,
I'll get in touch with my friends along the trail,
It'll be great,
It'll be awesome.
And then I got in touch with my dad and was like: hey, dad,
by the way, this spring this
I'm going to be hiking the Appalachian Trail.
And he was all right with it.
I think he's very excited now that I'm actually here
and doing it.
But I'm sure they were worried leading up to it
that I wasn't prepared or was going to run into bad weather
or whatever.
But now that I'm out here, now that I'm doing it,
I think they're just very excited that I'm in the woods
and using my skills.
They're so supportive.
That's good.
Yeah, supportive.
Bucky, you found the same thing.
Yeah,
It's a combination of pride and jealousy for my mom.
Mom's been doing the long trail
So she's got better and more gear than me.
So she was very supportive.
She knows it's my thing,
So, and Joe's- Joe's super proud.
He sent me a text about it.
It was a little heartbreaking.
There's what
Probably a thousand people who give it any serious thought
at all, for every person that actually makes it
to Springer Mountain.
Yeah, absolutely,
You guys started kind of early, didn't you?
We got to the like visitor center at Amacola Falls,
which is where a lot of through hikers originally register,
And that was February 6th, I think this past Monday.
So when we signed in at the register we were numbers 39
and 40 that had registered.
So we are on the early end.
I've got a good friend from Corsu Milton.
He started January 14th I think was his first day-
Oh no kidding.
And he just got out of the Smokies.
Getting out of the Smokies alive is an accomplishment,
Yeah, especially this early.
He had a rough go at it, but he's out and still kicking,
So that's good.
The trails kind of front loaded with a lot of really stiff hiking,
isn't it?
We thought Georgia would be a breeze
and we have hit a lot of difficulty.
Yeah, there's a switchback or two, I understand,
You know. yeah,
Some like spring loaded rocks.
Yeah,
Do you have a date in mind when you would like to be on Katahdin?
I have a job in the Adirondacks as a summit steward
again this summer,
So that starts Memorial Day weekend.
So I'm hoping I can get to Vermont,
maybe even New Hampshire, by then,
Even if we had done our super outrageous plan of 20 miles a day
from the start.
we wouldn't have gotten to Katahdin until early June.
So I don't think I'll be making it until I take some time off
of being a summit steward,
But hopefully I do at some point this summer.
I'd like to be done before July,
but I have no schedule.
I paid my rent for six months, though
I'd like to be done before July.
So tell me about the first week.
I have a couple of questions for you.
What time of day did you start?
I think it was 1045..
We started at Bringer Mountain.
So you started like 10,, 30,, 11 o'clock in the morning.
Yes,
How long was it before you decided
that this was the worst idea you've ever had?
It was like what? 445 that night?
Yeah,
Maybe a little later.
Maybe it was like five.
Well, yeah,
That day we started fast.
There was fairly level ground, at least in the beginning.
Our first maybe four miles.
We were doing like three miles an hour.
But then it started trickling
So we put our pack covers on.
Then it started coming down more,
So we put our rain gear on.
Then we kept thinking the shelter would be closed
And it wasn't.
And then finally, we saw the shelter from across the way.
It was not a loop,
It was a little loop.
It wasn't even a quarter mile away at that point.
But we were just so tired and hungry
We sat down in the middle of the trail with our eyes pointed at
the shelter
And we just ate trail mix and summer sausage
And, just like, took a 15, 20 minute break before continuing the
last two tenths of a mile maybe to the shelter.
And that was when we were like, wow, this is tough.
And our day was 15.8 miles, not including the .9 up,
So it was just about a 17 mile day.
That's a lot,
Yeah.
And that was our first day.
And our second day was supposed to be 19.
Yeah,
And our third was supposed to be 19.
Our next one was 10..
And then the one after that was five,
Yeah,
The 10 mile day. the second day, at some point along the way
I had twisted my leg or something and really hurt my knee.
That was no fun.
So the rest of the day is no fun, still hurting.
So the rest of that day was spent moving slow and like
slower and slower,
And then the rain started right back up again.
We got to this place with a couple campsites and there was a
spring a little ways down
And Bucky was like: all right, I'm going to go filter some
water,
You just sit here and try and stretch out your leg.
It was maybe a mile to the next shelter,
But we ended up just staying there.
We set up a tent in the rain, which is no fun when the
shelter is an option.
So we just set up a tent there and just passed out at
like five, six o'clock at night,
Cause we were just exhausted. after that 10 miles,
We would not go any further.
Yeah,
We couldn't have gone.
We couldn't have made it to that shelter.
There was like a little bit of an incline and it was enough to
just there was no way we could have done it.
Yeah,
I just so know that feeling.
The third day was five miles, because the first day when
we were at the shelter, the people there, they were all
saying, oh, there's a hot still only 15 miles down the
trail and we're all going to stay there.
So we were also planning on trying to get to that
hostel, which we only got the 10 miles in.
So the next five miles was up and over Blood Mountain.
Yeah,
It sounds terrible, but it actually wasn't that bad.
That was our third day was getting up Blood Mountain,
Yeah
And over. we stayed in the hostel and then the next
day we were already thinking about zeroing.
So, because Wade got some blisters and we just wanted
to heal,
Then it was 18 degrees that night, or snow the night
before.
We stayed the night again, but I think we even exited
the hostel for breakfast until one.
Yeah,
It was cold and snowy.
I have to tell you, I did the map because I was like,
oh, this would be cool,
Let me just kind of keep track of where they are
and everything.
I put the picture of you guys on Springer Mountain,
at Springer Mountain on the map, and I was like,
oh, okay,
So they're at Blood Mountain and it's the 12th. and
I did that and I said I wonder how far that is.
So I looked at it was like 28 miles and I said,
man,
Blood Mountain was a long time ago.
Yeah,
We put up with a little bit of a delay, but yeah,
we're still. we're not moving that fast.
You guys have trail names yet
Yeah,
I have not had one and nothing has really been
proposed for me,
So I'm still just regular way.
I have an old one, but it's a little shameful,
So I'm letting it slide and letting the new one
find its way.
And the story of behind it isn't necessarily good
for a scout podcast.
Shocker-
Well, Bucky's pretty good trail name. to begin with
I was thinking Scotch, I've been wearing my kill
and I, but we'll see,
They'll probably call you like skirt or something.
Yeah,
No guys, guys, it's Scotch,
It's Scotch.
Yeah,
It's skirt.
I kind of like it.
Yeah,
The next time you're going to zero out and you're
not going to be doing anything and I can sit and
talk to you,
It'd be kind of fun to track along and see where
you are and what you're up to.
Yeah,
Absolutely,
I know we've got towns that we want to zero.
I really appreciate you taking the time to talk
to me.
I'm totally envious of your being able to do
this.
I'm glad that you're happy and you're saying,
reasonably safe.
It'll be fun to keep track of where this goes.
It's fun to keep track of the old Eagle Scouts.
You guys have a blast and we'll keep up.
Yeah,
Absolutely,
We'll try and keep you updated as much as
possible and, yeah, I'd love to do this again,
Absolutely,
Okay,
Thanks so much, guys.
Thanks for taking the time.
Yeah, go to him.
Yep,
Thank you
Well. thanks so much for listening to this
338th edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Go over to scoutmastercgcom.
There's plenty of articles and all the past
editions of the podcast.
You can join us in the vast panorama of
social media outlets.
We have over 16,000 folks who like
Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
We have a course of tweeters on Twitter
and of course, we pin Pultritune's pictures
and proffer them publicly with a
parcel of prolific pinners on Pinterest.
You can watch us at ScoutmasterCG on
YouTube. but if you can't face
Facebook and Twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in Pinterest
and you don't put the? U in YouTube,
you know, don't worry about it, old timer.
Just zoom in to the late 90s
and send me an email.
I'm always available at
Clark at ScoutmasterCGcom.
that's C-L-A-R-K-E
at ScoutmasterCGcom
If all else fails. find a location
on a hill or a visible area,
safely away from tents.
Secure the area clear, side any
debris or brush and start a fire.
Set that fire, burn down to embers
and cover with a layer of green grass
or leaves, and on the resulting column
of smoke lay a dampened blanket.
Remove it to create distinct puffs
of smoke- Two puffs for all as well
and three puffs, for I have a question.
I'm constantly scanning the horizon
to look for smoke signals,
so I should be back in touch with you
very quickly By now. it should be
abundantly clear that the
Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications.
rather than myself, I'm not endorsed
or sponsored by any scouting organization
like the Boy Scouts of America. Nope,
it's just me talking into a microphone,
lending a hand to scouts and having
a little bit of fun along the way
and speaking of fun, and I hope
I had a lot of fun this week.
I hope you did too. Here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you
and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir? Until next time, everyone.
Thank you.